hi I'm Erik Bosse with Avengers infinity
board now available on digital HD we're
seeing some deleted scenes from the
movie and I made another video breaking
down a scene with Stannis and Gomorrah
but in this video let's look at this
interesting moment with the guardians of
the galaxy star-lord Drax and mantas why
was it deleted what easter eggs did this
scene contain and what does it tell us
about another way infinity war could
have gone spoiler warning in case they
say anything you don't want to hear and
let's take a look specifically the New
York
give me okay this thing would have been
said about halfway through the movie
after the Guardians were defeated in
nowhere and Thanos took amaura and
probably right after nebula escapes the
torture room and brings up that star map
and sends a message to mantas here's
star-lord as mopey and he's listening to
New York groove by Ace Frehley from kiss
Drax gets hold of the Zune that it's
playing on and stops at saying he's
tired of listening to it that Zune
belong to yondu remember at the end of
guardians the galaxy vol 2 cracklin gave
yondu's Zune to Peter quill after quill
gave crag Lin yondu's Yakka arrow
yondu picked us up from Earth and it
contains a bunch of 70's and 80's music
including Cat Stevens father and son
which quill played to grieve yondu at
the invent movie and now it turns out
New York groove which quill plays on
repeat to rally after losing Gamora
remember Drax is not a fan of music of
any kind listen to what he calls freely
and all the steps of the fact that Drax
is not among the category of beings that
dance the ones that appreciate music
let's keep watching
yeah he is helping more than you are
we lost Gamora because
another me seize the moment you tried to
kill her hey as Quillin tracks play hot
potato with the Zune we learned they
still haven't left nowhere yet and they
bark over the defeat they just went
through when quill pulled the trigger on
Gamora
but sanest heard his blast of the
bubbles with the reality stone really
the guardians are just kind of wallowing
and defeat here and well it's definitely
funny to see them bicker it's really two
minutes that don't really move the plot
forward that much and a movie that's two
and a half hours long definitely needs
all the narrative moment and they can
get but the story related function of
the scene comes up in the next foot
would stop that blinking light a
blinking yellow light indicates an
important secret coded message this was
your job you didn't see the blinking
yellow light did but you said if it was
yellow but at melon Brown flush it dumps
wasn't talking about the coded message
here mantis is transfixed by this
blinking yellow light which looks kind
of green to me I just assume they had
adjusted the color yet on this footage
some good jokes ear the insectoid mantis
being distracted like a bug to a bug
zapper and Drax thinking the toilet
Maxim applies to the coded message
channel alert but we learned the exact
contents of those messages in the final
part five hours we have 22 messages from
nebula Kimura is alive to Titan why
aren't you responding why aren't you
responding
are you getting my important coded
secret messages tight okay so really the
point of the scene was to show how the
Guardians knew to come to tightening and
how they ended up with Iron Man
spider-man and Doctor Strange but really
nebula is outgoing message to them in
the previous scene kind of covered that
information so when the Guardians sneak
attack Iron Man's group it actually
comes off as more of a surprise which
makes that whole squabble scene a lot
more exciting but there are two
interesting details here one of the
guardians have been sitting in nowhere
four or five hours and that nebula
assumed vanos was bringing Gamora
to take you five hours kind of confuses
the timeline of these events assuming
this scene would take place before
gomorrah's death on Boromir I mean why
else motivate the audience and quill in
this scene with the prospect of saving
Gamora why would it have taken five
hours for Thanos to go more do travel -
for mere the guy had the space stone he
could just go there instantaneously
after that second detail he definitely
makes sense that nebula would tell the
guardians to meet her untighten in that
outgoing message assuming those storm
so she looked at it might have included
thanasis plans to rendezvous with the
Black Order on Titan and bring all the
stones together but it's a little odd
that nebula would tell quill that Thanos
is for sure bringing Gamora there nebula
just heard the two of them saying they
were headed to Boromir
that's not a huge mistake this is all
fine it just kind of forces us to
imagine assumptions that characters are
making off screen at the end of the day
a shot of nebula sending mantas a
message saying hey meet me on Titan is
just a lot more straightforward but a
question I'll leave you with do you
think infinity war as a whole could have
used more comedic relief scenes like
this one or was this cut justified
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me I da vas following the
rockstars on Twitter for updates under
videos like this video share it around
and subscribed into rock stars for all
the big of interest theories an MCU
updates that you need to know about
thanks for watching